Charlie you've talked about how shy you
were when you were in maybe grade school
or teenager can you think of any stories
that would explain that sure
I uh I mean I remember one time when I
was in elementary school
and I
was so scared to talk in class I had
spent all day not talking at all I had
spent all day not talking at all that by
the time I got home my mom asked me how
school was and my voice kind of was like
cracked and croaked because it was
literally the first time that I had
opened my mouth that day because I was
really shy to talk in school especially
I would say that school was my I was my
most anxious in general just being I
think it was just something about being
like a young girl and having boobs like
I was scared to scared to show off my
body too much I was scared to draw any
attention to myself I didn't want to be
I was very much like a teacher's pet but
I don't know what it was I just felt
like standing out might get me in
trouble somehow so I just really kept to
myself I kept really quiet I remember
the one time I ever got a laugh in class
was was and I never talked in class like
I'm not a clown I'm not a like a Class
Clown I'm not I'm always in the front of
the class I'm always like the teacher's
pet I'm always answering questions but
never like shooting you know I'm I'm
never hanging out with the kids in the
back of the classroom talking
um this one girl we were in history
class and we were talking about politics
and she was and she was saying well if
if this happens then this happens and if
that happens and that's gonna happen and
I just turned around and I was just like
what are you psychic and then everybody
exploded and laughed during the class
and that was literally the one and only
time I was like in Middle School that
was the one and only time I ever like
Gotta Laugh in class or like talked out
of turn that wasn't like a teacher
asking a question but I was just a very
quiet quiet kid I even have a story of
like eating in the bathroom one time
sure yeah because I was too scared to
eat because no one wanted to let me sit
with them and I was too scared to eat by
myself so I just went and sat in the
bathroom and eat by myself uh it was
really really a dark time
yeah that guy was entirely too shy yeah
we would go to the VA Hospital next next
I was me and like a couple people that
were also the sort of Misfits and then
the VA Hospital told the school and we
couldn't go there anymore wow
how old were you when you became less
shy
foreign
I think 24
I would say when I was 24 I moved to New
York and I had this deep desire to do
stand up and I don't know where it came
from I don't know why what demon and
Hell decided to put this as something
that I wanted to do
um on my heart or in my gut you know but
it was just something that I wanted to
do I wanted to get up I wanted to do
stand up I wanted to tell jokes like the
girl that never talked the girl that
never
um was a Class Clown or anything like
that like wanted to go to New York a
city I'd never been to I grew up very
like overprotected Haitian Christian
girl
um in on the East Coast so it just was
something that was
really outside of anything I'd ever
identified with but yet it was something
that I wanted to do so I kind of had to
like
I had to overcome my shyness and do the
thing that was on my heart to do which
was to go try stand up
um so I would say and I did that when I
was 24. and that was the first time that
I had like
really overcome some some shyness
so you graduated from college in
Massachusetts and then you went to New
York and and how that first time getting
up in front of the crowd how many people
were sitting there uh it was an open mic
I think it was maybe 10 or 15 people
other comics
I'm including the bartender possibly the
host of the show I think it was like
about 15 people in the venue where I got
up and did my first jokes
how did it go
poorly and wonderfully at the same time
I I drank a bit too much I had like uh I
had a shot with a beer or something I
was 24 so I could mix alcohols and that
was fine and still wake up the next
morning and go to work but that is no
longer but I was 24 I could still do
that I had a shot in a beer because they
had a special at the bar and I was
already like that was enough to get me
like Sauced before I went up and did my
show
um
but what happened right before there was
so I had brought this girl with me uh
who was at my job so I was working at
Columbia University at the time in the
um in the I was an administrative
assistant in the film department
actually and uh there was a new intern
that had started that day and we had
just gotten to talking and I told her
that I was going to try stand up for the
first time that night and she insisted
on coming even though I had told no one
and I wanted no one to come she insisted
on coming
and then she came and she had like very
very short hair and the comic before me
made fun of her hair he was doing some
like crowd work he made fun of her hair
they get into this huge fight they get
into this screaming match
right before I'm supposed to go up
um it totally like messes up the vibe of
the whole event
and instead of canceling it like the
host is like should we cancel it like
should we keep going they decide to keep
going and they're like all right well I
guess we're gonna keep going next comic
Charlotte
something like it's just this horrible
vibe in the venue and I have to get up
and I'm Sauced and I'm nervous and these
this is literally the first time I'm
going to be saying these jokes that I've
written ever
um and then I got a few laughs maybe you
know but I think it was like way more
important that I went up and did it and
because that is the barrier you know the
barrier is getting up and doing it it's
it's not so much I hardly remember if
anybody laughed or not I just remember
it was just such an awkward night it was
such a memorable night for being so
ridiculous
for all I wanted to do was just try
stand up for the first time so
yeah I don't remember if anybody laughed
but
it was both wonderful and terrible at
the same time
do you think that doing stand-up made
you less shy or were there other things
that happened you're out of your home
state you're in New York City of all
places
you're riding the subway I think yeah I
think the whole thing I think yeah the
whole thing made me less shy the whole
experience of moving to New York of
getting up in front of people of doing
something that I thought people might
judge me for because it was so not
um how people know me people know me to
be Christian Haitian quiet you know
church girl kind of you know athlete at
school you know
it's strong student kind of person
I'm in the I'm like the director of like
the community services on student
council like I'm like someone who's
clearly gonna go on their way to college
like I'm just I don't think that I was
someone that people saw as a performer
you know or maybe I didn't see myself as
a performer but I think it was so much
more than just the Performing that made
me less shy it was the
not being afraid to live authentically
that made me less shy not being afraid
to quit my job that made me unhappy and
do something that I thought might make
me happy whether or not stand up made me
happy it's made me happy it's made me
sad it's made me all kinds of things all
the time but I genuinely think just
living my life and just living my life
the life that I want not what my mom
wants not what my religion wants when I
was religious not what the world might
want from me because I'm a black woman
or something like that what people might
expect from me or because I'm Haitian
whatever it is I think what has really
made me less shy is
really really doing my best to be myself
and being okay with being myself in
front of people
is shine is still an issue for you
absolutely shyness is very much an issue
for me for for sure
I think it's something that
um
I don't want to say it's something that
I'll never get over I don't think I'll
always be shy but I think that there's
just something about me that like finds
a lot of comfort in being by myself a
lot of comfort in just being in small
groups of people small intimate
situations I don't love big crowds I
don't love being the center of attention
all the time you know so I definitely
think that's a part of my personality
but I think it's just taking a new form
the more I'm able to be myself it's it's
it's more about
um
it's less about being shy and more about
knowing that I'm safe to be myself in
public I'm safe to be myself in front of
people and I can still be like I can be
on this show I can be on film courage
and I can still be a shy person and
that's that's still who I am but right
now what you're seeing is is me being
um a shy person who's comfortable and
feel safe when people see me as who I am
and I don't feel like I have to put on
any kind of Errors to to do things that
might be scary or might maybe nervous or
anything like that
what about in a TV writer's room
do you feel that you have to be more of
an extrovert or is that accepted because
would you say most writers are Hermits
I would definitely say that a lot of
writers can be introverts
for sure and I definitely think a lot of
writers can struggle to speak up in the
writer's room because they're shy I'm
one of those people and I have I just
had my friend Lamar Woods on the working
writer and we talked about his anxiety
and his he is he takes medication for
anxiety and
um I myself am someone who's diagnosed
with a lot of anxiety and just having to
pitch at the level of consistency that
you have to pitch at in the writer's
room in order to contribute in the way
that you really should be contributing
as a writer it can really be daunting
sometimes especially if you're a
perfectionist if you're someone who
overthinks if you're someone who is not
confident in their ideas uh it really
can be challenging and it really forces
you to kind of get comfortable with
having bad ideas heard out loud with you
know not getting your ideas put into the
show with
um being vocal even if you think your
idea is not that good you know it's
really about uh contributing over
everything
um that is how you are an effective
writer in the writer's room is your is
your voice it's your contribution and
you if you're somebody that is shy you
know what I've tried to do is really
look at the anxiety that I've had in the
writer's room as an opportunity to get
over my shyness as a way to like get to
the heart of what is really going on
which is that oh I'm struggling with
perfectionism oh I'm struggling with
overthinking I'm not in the moment I'm
not present because I'm thinking so much
about how this pitch will be received
that I can't listen so that I can
contribute and participate in the way
that I need to to be a good writer for
the room and I think it's also something
that just makes you kind of have to like
you have to put yourself aside a little
bit because at the end of the day it is
work it is a job and it's heavy lifting
you know the writer's room is a lot of
work and when we're letting our anxiety
and our fear take over it takes over our
ability to do our job so it's it's it's
not easy I've definitely had to struggle
with it I know so many writers that have
struggled with it really good writers it
doesn't matter you know like it doesn't
mean that just because
um I do it a lot that it's not hard so
it can be hard especially if you're shy
but I think it is good for I think it's
good for for our
um to build up gumption it's just build
up a lot of like I have to talk so I'm
gonna have to just be confident that
whatever I say is good enough and it's
gonna have to be good good enough for me
and that's because my speaking is more
important than protecting myself from
failure which is what is really going on
underneath
I like that gumption do you do you still
do you think when you let's say you go
back home to Massachusetts you've now
been in two of the most competitive
cities LA and New York most people never
leave their home state those are two
kind of scary cities yes do you feel
differently when you go back there or or
does it do you slip into Old Charlotte
that's interesting because I do feel
differently when I go back there and Old
Charlotte always felt that she didn't
belong in those places anyway Old
Charlotte when you know when we lived in
Florida when we lived in Massachusetts
with my family I never felt like that I
felt at home but I didn't feel that this
was the place that I belonged I didn't
feel like I belonged in these places
because they were too slow and there's
nothing wrong with slow slow is amazing
at this stage of my life slow is amazing
but at that stage I wanted more action I
wanted more challenge I wanted more
Adventure and those places weren't
giving that to me and I do feel that
when I go back
um people treat me different I don't
think I've changed that much because
I've always felt like I didn't
particularly belong in these smaller
slower places but people make people
will be like well Charlotte's back from
the big city and they'll say things like
I could never live there you know what I
mean and these places cases are
difficult places to live they're
expensive they're competitive they're
loud you're probably far from family so
you're dealing with loneliness and
isolation possibly they're difficult
um but I think life is about living
about choosing your own adventure you
know I think that we have that choice
and I think that it is honestly a sacred
one I think life is very precious and I
think we have the choice about
what do we want do we want to stay in
this place or do we want something
different and I wanted something
different and I don't think there's
anything wrong with choosing either both
can be challenging for for whatever
reason
um but I chose this particular challenge
um and I'm I think I'm better for it